there's this picture of you floating
around that I found where you're on the
red carpet and look at this you're
flipping off are you flipping on it
looks like you're flipping off the
photographers yeah
that's supposed to do in this town thank
you let me look at me right now look
wink wink at us and I'm just like no and
then can I clip yeah you do whatever you
want here yeah none of this is airing we
decided that a long time ago so in the
audience all of us are being sent to a
secret island no Paul was not coming
with us to an island where there's no
natural laws here's the point the point
is that you're flipping off the
photographers were you mad at them in
that moment where you just do no my
friend just like passed by and was
recording so I was like hey and then I
forgot that there was the hundreds of
you forgot you forgot the paparazzi of
paparazzi are there and so it looked
like you were flipping them off yeah
well whatever yeah do you have that
broiler
do you have that relationship with your
friends where you see him and just as
like a fun joke you I say what [ __ ] and
then I give him a hug and then like when
we leave I'm like bye
that's so many that's so many mixed
messages all at once
big smile [ __ ] and then a ha oh I'm
back in again and then flip off just
like I wouldn't know what was going I
see so so [ __ ] for you it's like a term
of endearment yeah it means like
sweetheart wait till you have kids I
know I can't do my vows no yeah I bow my
vows like be like you know I love you
[ __ ] yeah
I've always I knew when I saw you [ __ ]
that we would be together like that yeah
you look like you were sort of almost
either falling asleep during your
wedding probably I probably will be